[Music]
it seems to me and you can't believe
everything you read on the internet so I
want you to certainly fact check me as
needed but that you you also have or
have had some internal rules so you can
you can use your external environment to
assist but but I read that and again
feel free to correct but making rules
the importance of making rules rules
like you can sit here and write or you
can sit here and do nothing
but you can't sit here and do anything
else that that was always and still is
when I go off to write that's my biggest
rule could you speak to that yeah cuz I
would go down to my lovely little gazebo
at the bottom of the garden sit down and
I'm absolutely allowed not to do
anything I'm allowed to set up my desk
I'm allowed to stare out at the world
I'm allowed to do anything I like as
long as it isn't anything not allowed to
do a crossword not allowed to read a
book allowed to phone a friend not
allowed to you know make a claim model
of something I all I'm allowed to do is
absolutely nothing or right and what I
love about that is I'm giving myself
permission to write or not write but
writing is actually more interesting
than doing nothing after a while you
know you sort of sit there and you've
been staring out the window now for five
minutes and it kind of loses its charm
well actually might as well write
something and and it's hard
I'm as a writer I'm more easily
distractible I have a three-year-old son
he is the epitome of cuteness and charm
he's it's more fun playing with him than
it is writing which means if I'm going
to be writing I need to do it somewhere
I don't have a three-year-old some
singing to me asking me to read to him
demanding my attention and I think
that's it I think it's a really just a
solid rule for writers it's like yeah
you don't have to write you have
permission to not write that you don't
have permission to do anything else
you